i thought they were gonna come through
the wall
[Music]
no no no
i'm not here i'm tim
this is brittany that was the neighbor
right here
yeah what's it called
wait wait this is brittany she's the one
who got here
i'm i live here this is my friend
and then this is my
neighbor that hit her i wasn't even here
i was outside
she's on the phone to dispatch it which
one which okay
all right
here's what she said
like i said i wasn't in here
i literally just banged on the door like
or through the wall bam
and i'm sleeping
shut the fuck up
and so i like came out i was like what
what's going on
he wasn't here
dog wasn't here
okay then what's up i came out and i was
like what's going on
right to the fucking mouth
okay okay
i don't know right there possibly okay
he is an older man
i i honestly don't know when you get
knocked the fuck out
you don't really
he busted oh my shit my nose my mouth
all right
all i wanted to do was like what was
what was just serving here and he was
like shut the fuck up boom
was he white black he's white
does he have hair
yeah
gray hair yeah gray hair he's older guys
they're about this tall
that and that guy lives right there in
that room and that's where the wall
would go he was saying bang bang bang
that's what we've seen up we just we
just moved in here yesterday but i saw
him like yes last night
what do you want
what the fuck
put it down motherfucker put it down
put it down get on the ground down
back up get out here right now
get out of here
get on the ground no
they hit that wall so hard i thought
they were gonna come through the wall
stop
what you're gonna what's going
oh
put it down
motherfucker get down
put it down get off the ground
back up back up back up get out here
right now
get out here
get on the ground no
they hit that wall so hard i thought
they were going to come through the wall
but you're going to push the gun away
these people over there were
all right